what we're going to do in this video is
talk about the two major ideologies you
will hear about in the united states and
that's the liberal ideology and the
conservative ideology and the liberal
ideology is often associated with the
democratic party
and the conservative ideology is often
associated with the republicans
but be very careful this does not mean
that every democrat will have a
stereotypically liberal view on every
major issue or that every republican
would have a stereotypically
conservative view on every issue we're
all individuals and many of us will have
different opinions on these issues and
might lean conservative on some and
might lean liberal on others
but just to get a sense of what liberal
and conservative tend to mean in the
united states on issues that you will
hear about let's go through this list of
issues and i encourage you to pause this
video and have your own go at what do
you think would be the liberal or the
conservative viewpoint on each of these
issues
so let's start with arguably one of the
most contentious issues in the united
states and that's of abortion
a liberal would view this as a
reproductive rights issue they view this
as the right of a woman to choose what
to do with her body so they tend to be
pro the right of a woman to have an
abortion to choose to have an abortion
and will self-label themselves
pro-choice
conservatives on the other hand will
often view this as a a life issue that
they view the developing fetus as a life
and like any life has certain rights and
so they would typically be against
abortion and would self-label themselves
pro-life
affirmative action is another
contentious issue this is the idea and
we've talked about in other videos that
proactive measures should be taken in
order to address wrongs of the past or
in order to address inequality today or
discrimination today and it often takes
form in can race be considered as a part
of admissions into say higher education
liberals tend to be in favor of
affirmative action while conservatives
tend to be against it
the liberal point of view is yes we have
a very unequal society there's a lot of
discrimination
race should be considered a factor in
order to ease that discrimination a
conservative today might argue wait a
second we want to be a racially blind
society and so we do not want race to be
a factor
guns is another very contentious issue
liberals will often cite guns as a major
factor in a lot of the crime and
shootings in the united states and they
would tend to be pro-gun
control
conservatives on the other hand will
often cite the second amendment the
right to bear arms and they would say
look this isn't when we see mass
shootings or crime it's not a gun issue
there's other issues at play and so they
would be more pro-gun
rights
they would generally be against gun
control and want more rights for gun
owners
on a related note on crime liberals tend
to view it as a social
issue what are the underlying causes say
poverty or something else that is
causing crime they would also be very
concerned with defendants rights
citing examples where certain ethnic
groups certain races might be
disproportionately accused or
disproportionately punished
conservatives on the other hand tend to
favor tougher policing and tougher laws
saying that okay it's interesting to
look at the social issues and yes we do
need certain rights but at the end of
the day you don't want to be too easy on
crime so tougher policing
and tougher
laws
moving into the economic sphere the
liberal view on taxes is generally that
it's okay and some liberals will even
view it as a tool for building social
equality they would say hey look if
someone's got to pay for something maybe
it should be the rich they can afford to
pay more and it'll help level the
playing field a little bit and so okay
especially
on and i'll put the rich in quotes
because different people would have
different standards for what it means to
be rich
and conservatives generally are not okay
with taxes
they would say that it is a disincentive
to work they would say that it's a
friction on the economy they would say
that it would reduce investment that
could create jobs the liberal and
conservative views on spending is
related to that on taxes a stereotypical
view of liberals is that hey they might
like to tax especially on the rich and
then spend it especially on social
programs okay
especially
on social
programs maybe welfare system or free
health care these would all be things
that a liberal point of view would be
more likely to support a conservative
viewpoint is not okay
with government spending that the
government should be as small as
possible and spend as little as possible
perhaps the only exception or one of the
few exceptions would be except on
military spending except
on
military where conservative might be in
favor of more spending there in order to
have a strong and muscular military
now related to this idea on the size of
government is that of regulation
liberals tend to be in favor
of regulation especially if they're in
regards to things like preserving the
environment
conservatives tend to be against
regulation saying that okay maybe some
baseline regulation is okay but it needs
to be minimal because the more
regulations you have once again these
are frictions on the economy it makes it
harder to start a business it makes it
harder to grow it makes it more
expensive to do things so they tend to
be against regulation
last but not least and this is just a
survey of some of the big issues you
will hear about the united states is the
military and i already touched on it a
liberal is likely to want a military but
they would probably want something that
does just the base services of what you
would expect from a military if people
are invading our borders that the
military is there to protect us so maybe
we could call it
basic
basic military
while a conservative would say hey you
can't get complacent even if we're at a
time of peace even if people haven't
crossed our borders in a long time you
don't know what's around the corner look
at history there's all sorts of
complacent societies that eventually get
overrun and so they would want a strong
and muscular military and they'll make
the argument that the stronger your
military is perhaps maybe the less
likely that you would have to use it
because people would not even want to
mess with you they wouldn't even want to
think about messing with you if you have
a strong and muscular posture
so i'll leave you there on these general
ideas and once again these are
stereotypical views you will meet many
people including yourself who might have
a mix of these views for example it
would not be too difficult to find a
democrat who for example might be
pro-choice but against affirmative
action who is pro-gun control who is
maybe someplace in the middle here on
crime who is economically conservative
who's not okay with taxes who wants them
to be as little as possible who is not
okay with government spending who's
maybe middle of the road on regulation
and maybe they like a strong muscular
military and likewise you could find
republicans who similarly have a mix of
viewpoints